in Washington a showdown on the Senate
floor today over the Keystone XL
pipeline the vote to approve the
controversial pipe project has vague
political implications but the energy
implications have diminished since the
project was first proposed the economy
has moved on oil has moved on well chief
Washington correspondent a Peter Cook
has more Peter first on the politics
eyes you supporters have the 60 votes
that they need to get this through the
Senate well that is the big question
still at this point Betty I can tell you
that Mary Landrieu the Democrat from
Louisiana really started this fight over
the Keystone pipeline in this lame duck
session of Congress she says she feels
comfortable that they're going to get to
60 yet we still don't know publicly who
that magic 60th vote is going to be we
can count 59 at this point but we cannot
get to 60 we don't know exactly who that
would be to get them over the top but
still she and other supporters are
feeling confident they were dealt a blow
yesterday when for Democrats are being
targeted for support indicated they're
going to vote no those four Democrats
had all expressed support for the
pipeline at various stages over the past
couple years but they've all decided and
that includes Amy Klobuchar mark Udall
Chris Coons and Tim Johnson that they're
not going to shortcut this process the
review process they would allow the
normal process to take place here and
Betty even if Mary Landrieu can get the
magic 60 votes she needs for this
project on the Senate floor tonight 615
you still have the prospect of President
Obama standing there and deciding
whether or not he's going to sign this
into law and every indication is so far
from senators I'm talking to that if it
reaches the President's desk he's going
to veto it so this could be a fight
really that's going nowhere it could go
nowhere Peter and this is primarily why
the reason why right Peter that the
energy industry has largely moved on
from Keystone Oh Betty this has been a
six-year fighting to be to be clear the
energy industry including top energy
associations here in the United States
are actively fighting in favor of the
Keystone pipeline make leaked this
project should happen but the reality on
the ground is the energy industry has
largely moved on so much has changed in
the last six years first of all you've
got to look at the explosion of US oil
production so much more barrels per day
produced in the United States compared
to 2000 a you also have to look at the
price of oil which of course recently
has dropped
about 75 bucks a barrel that raises
questions about whether this is an
economical project as it was just a few
years ago and then finally you also got
a look at what's happening in the
interim in terms of moving this oil to
market you've got rail capacity in
Alberta alone will be up to 700,000
barrels a day by 2015 Betty this oil is
moving is moving along other pipelines
it's moving by rail and there's an
argument that can be made that maybe
Keystone isn't as important as it once
was certainly that's not the case to
Canada Betty and that's a wild card here
this is a critically important project
to the Canadians it would be a big blow
to us Canadian relations if it didn't
happen I agree on that Peter now any
sense though that this debate has
actually helped Mary Landrieu and her
run off well the sense i get from
talking both to lawmakers here and
analysts here as well as folks down in
Louisiana is that it hasn't hurt her
chances but Betty this is going to be an
uphill fight all along the polls show
are trailing bill casting the race for
that Louisiana Senate seat and it's
going to be a lot to overcome not clear
that this vote alone is enough to put
Mary Landrieu over the top but it hasn't
hurt her chances it's probably helped
but still an uphill fight all right
Peter thank you so much our chief
Washington correspondent Peter Cook on
the hill